when the South Tower collapsed my
immediate reaction and his was to
embrace each other I didn't know him he
didn't know me but in that moment we
were to human beings watching something
so horrific that our only response was
that basic human response of needing to
be with someone person after person was
coming towards us and we knew we were
getting closer as we started to see
these people who look like like ghosts
they were completely covered in the
white ash from the collapse of the
building in creating a museum about an
atrocity how do you make the decision of
what is appropriate to show when does
the presentation of this audio tape or
this particular picture violate the
memory of the people we are charged to
commemorate the layout of the museum
also tries very hard to be sensitive to
visitors to signal within the exhibition
where there was challenging material or
even more challenging material so if and
when someone does feel overwhelmed we
wanted to find a way that visitors could
make their way out quickly and not have
to eerie traumatize as they were exiting
and so we developed these things with
the exhibition team called emotional
exits ways that people can essentially
exit and go into a safe neutral zone
which is the envelope that surrounds the
historic exhibition we made the decision
to segregate the history exhibit in the
largest enclosed space at bedrock from a
visitor experience logic it meant that
people could come to this place and make
the choice of whether or not they were
ready or they wanted to go into the
history exhibit where we have to tell
the story and the story involves
difficult imagery
choices was really one of the hardest
things that I've ever really been
involved with in terms of designing it
is a space that is dedicated to telling
the story of those people in the towers
who had the impossible choice the choice
lyst choice of whether to stay in a
burning building or whether to jump we
have some contextualizing information on
the outside as well as warnings just
about the level of intensity within the
exhibition itself as you make your way
around we have quotes a number of
first-person quotes about people's
reactions and impressions of witnessing
that event and then as you make your way
you see a series of slowly fading images
and it was just about stripping away as
much design as possible and just
allowing the images and quotes to
communicate what happened this is a part
of the story that we asked the question
do we have to include this and the
resounding answer from family members
from first responders from all of the
constituencies was you can't tell the
story of 9/11 and not tell this story
this is a museum about all of us having
experienced something having witnessed
something unprecedented that changed the
way so many people think about the world
and it needed to be a place where we
weren't telling you what you needed to
know we were telling you what we wanted
you to be thinking about
you